[Music]
the cinema allows me to escape
to forget everyday life
[Music]
yet when there are others
I like it like the English in a
film I don't have to feel
chills
witi fabi their  obviously we found it
when we are in love with
the Omanis and it provokes emotions
and its deeply
personal touch to me your magic of
cinema
[Music]
they face couiza certainly arguing that
which means losing or parking what
we wanted
benfeld  scorsese or the moreau price which is
extracted langon and anne frank instyle
hacker news
[Music]
[Applause]
my favorite and big lebowski and its
annexes
spoiled by toyota verso-s citizen kane
[Music]
chinese film
the cinema the yogi on horses the image is
then we cry for the same
would have for the same it is even a
freighter hurt the best is
part of southern kansas in france shown
click it is permanent magic mouse
[  Music]
[  Applause]
this game
[Music]
and